I've been telling a couple of time I
haven't really baked in about 15 years I
prefer to let other people do the baking
so that I don't burn my house down it's
pretty delicious happen Cheers
tricky shots hmm oh yeah
oh wow that's delicious do it again oh I
overdid it makes you really respect like
birthday clown
success that's it how cute is that it's
like little chocolate pottery I think
they'd be really good with fruit
chocolates gently push the cut corner of
the bag into the center of the cupcake
to that puncture oh yeah see that oh
it's amazing
well see in the middle it's like a
volcano of deliciousness see good cherry
is perfect what's our next recipe Toll
House frozen cookie dough Oh guys these
cookies are already made are you kidding
me
alright so easy we could just pop them
in the oven
oh good
hey guys I just want to say it like one
more time it was amazing baking with you
today hmm
it's amazing cake like home yeah I
really sort of have like a newfound
respect for your people who bake all the
time now see you later